Guy Talk guy talk all right how far do
you boys go with grooming yourselves
like in terms of like okay okay okay
okay
question question one question one do
you shave your chest do your chest hair
I don't have chest here
like
three little strands of hair that is
just like there's just like three little
strands of my manly Hood just being like
you're a big boy you're a man you're a
big boy I don't isn't it weird though
how a hair grows on the body and like
which is completely different random
assortments why can't we just grow like
fur like a monkey like all over what do
you mean like my legs are hairy my arms
are hairy and my chest's a little hairy
but like not much else and it feels just
kind of random when my body was like
listen yeah and it's like at least the
[__] monkeys were like let's commit
yeah
monkeys come here with having hair all
over they were like let's just get it
all over like why do this mishmash
[__] like I don't know uh but what
other types of groups all right armpit
hair Juju cut or shaves those shave
those no I think I I someone told me
that if you cut it you sweat less so I I
tried that because I feel like I my
armpits in the summer here [__]
faucets yeah but I find that it only
helped slightly I think I think the
problem I have I think I remember
cutting my armpit hair once in my life
because I was like okay it's getting a
bit long it's kind of a little bit
[__] scissors yeah it's just like
trim [__] yeah what the [__] you don't
you don't use a [__] shaver
I wasn't you're gonna [__] Barber to
be like let me let me stop
I wasn't even in the shower I just like
went to my room got a pair of scissors
and just went bro what the [__] do you
know do you have like a body grooming
thing not when I was in high school oh
okay okay
no I was in high school so like I barely
had any body hair that I needed to share
I couldn't even grow a proper beard back
yeah so I was like okay you know it's
kind of getting long and annoying so
just like maybe just go half right yeah
yeah so that it's out of the way yeah
problem is and this is the same problem
when you shave your uh genital area is
that there's a point where it gets
really [__] itchy
and it gets so annoying so like after a
while like the new hair is starting to
grow and then this itchiness just comes
and it's like your armpits are just
constantly she just turns off [__]
monkey you're just doing this the whole
that's why I never shave like all the
way I don't I don't like I don't go
right to the skin I always leave like a
little bit but I mean like I uh I've
recently discovered the power of like
shaving your armpits as well and I've
just realized how much easier it is to
get deodorant to [__] stage oh yeah
yeah like like I understand and the
effects of deodorant now like like anime
fans anyone who goes to Convention maybe
this is a [__] life hack they don't
know what deodorant because you know
sometimes when uh when I was like a
teenager I'm like my armpit hair was
like really really long no matter how
much deodorant I would spray on there or
no matter how much I would shower for
some reason there would always be this
like [__] lingering smell there that
I could never get yeah because when your
hair is long here you're basically just
putting deodorant on the hair yeah
you're basically putting deodorant on
the hair and the sweat just sticks to
the hair as well yeah
um and I love when we talk about this
[__] because someone always diagnoses us
with someone
was like actually that yeah this happens
when I talk about the pimple on my ass
as well yeah yeah like someone said what
it was and I was like actually that
could be right yeah they were like yeah
I don't know that means you've been
you've been taking too much dick off the
ass yeah yeah exactly exactly not I mean
I feel like guys don't talk enough about
you know self-care and self-grooming
techniques
um and I know just like it was at least
uh literally like three four years ago
where I had you know I went a group of
guys in England and we just randomly
brought up this topic and I was like
[__] this is literally the first time
I've ever had this conversation in my
life okay okay sorry yeah every guy has
a different grooming technique every guy
takes care of themselves differently and
sometimes just by talking about it you
realize oh I never shaved my armpit hair
before because no one really talks
does it not get itchy not if uh I I do
it with like
um an electric razor right and I have
that's good yeah yeah like like electric
razor and I have one specifically just
for like my body and it's just like a
number one I use everything
[Applause]
[Music]
you just started you know going to town
here and then you're like well my beard
is getting bigger okay hold on it's not
like that I'm not like
it's like it's like start from the left
side on both sides like one of the other
gifts done right and it's like I'm I
never I never do it like I've always
I've always washed myself completely and
then I always like trim whatever it is
all right but it's just the prince I
don't know I don't I don't trim my balls
that often I don't know yeah I was gonna
ask how often do you like this should be
like the perfect spot for a man yeah
yeah this is this would be the person so
yeah that was the question I was gonna
ask because I was going to ask how often
do you shave your like genital area okay
so it's a TMI I feel like
[__] it
I don't have like a well monthly time to
do it I don't have that either but like
if you if you hash it out over a year
how often are you doing it [__] those
probably like once a month I reckon as
you can tell with my beard my hair grows
really quickly to the point and I have
like I have hair growing on like really
annoying parts of my body as well uh
like I I had to start waxing feed hair
right oh wow and it's not like my feet
were like furry they'd just be like
they'd just be like men got big feet
yeah yeah they'd just be like odd
strands of hair like randomly on my feet
that would just get caught up uh
whenever I you know put on shoes or
uh whenever whenever I just go about
daily life and it would just get
annoying so one day I just got kind of
like I said he has like a waxer so I
just like [__] just got it like got
the waxing just [__] wax all my hair
off my feet and I just it's just nice
now it's just nice and they always talks
about laser hair removal I've never said
anything she's like you should laser
hair removal I think mailing one's all
body hair eliminated from the Earth but
she's very quick to recommend it I've
never had it I don't know who anyone who
has yeah yeah yeah sounds like it hurts
I think so I've seen videos of it of
people getting it done and like I think
the ones in Japan they literally get it
because in Japan it's very common for
people to do it yes for their face
because they because in Japan obviously
clean shaven is like the look and some
people who maybe grow stubble they're
just like just get get rid of it yeah I
don't have a [__] shave this one yeah
I think uh in Japan as well a lot of
guys get what's called a Vio yeah so
it's like the V the I and then the O
what wait wait wait wait wait wait the V
is like your you know where the hair
would be like in the front yeah it's
shaped like a V yeah the I is your ass
crack yeah and the O is oh your [__]
oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
wait wait wait wait wait hold on hold on
what are they doing with this Vio so
basically it's the areas that they're
getting rid of the hair
oh yeah so when you get when you go get
a lot of like hair removal uh like laser
removal stuff yeah they usually ask like
where do you want it done and the most
common one is a Vio so it's just like
getting rid of all the hair there
because you know I guess the general
consensus is no one really wants uh a
hairy [__] that's true yeah which you
know I get I just I just feel weird just
searching up ass hair clinic removal
booking in a slot pulling my ass down so
I'm fine someone just fires a [__]
laser beam at my ass
I've seen videos of it it literally
looks like a kind of like a taser and it
makes the sound of a taser like they
they press it it's clicking it is it
like clicking a bunch yeah it's clicking
a bunch I I apparently it hurts yeah
what is the deal with their hair on like
your the knuckles of your toe like what
is the evolutional point of that that's
that's that's the uh that's the hair
yeah I know I have that but it's so
[__] annoying I don't know I kind of
like it what because if I touch him my
oh it feels weird but also what is the
[__] point of that I have no I'm
looking at it I'm like this sure sure
it's there but I'm like what is the
evolutional benefit of me having four
[__] strands of hair on my like big
okay his here's the question do your
hair have like a growth limit of in
Terms like oh yeah I think so I don't
[__] trim it uh how long does it get
well my toes yeah on your toes I don't
know like that yeah mine's about that
and and you that doesn't bother you like
that long and it doesn't bother you no
no like that like as in like between
these two days about that oh like that
oh my mind gets [__] long mine gets
like that which is which I it which is
why I like I which is why I had to start
[__] waxing it because it's just
gonna be a toe yeah it just it just gets
like caught up in like so many like
different things I I saw um right I feel
like I always have to like nose hair is
super annoying for me I swear I trim it
literally one day later it's back I'm
like how the [__] does this happen yeah
and so I'm like I I was walking in the
train station and they had these little
pop-up things where they were like 20
minutes whack they wax your nose and
you're gone literally in like a train
station okay and I was like man maybe I
should do that but I've used those uh
I've used those things that you see a
lot in the morning
[Music]
you see those [__] videos people pull
and then they pull the stick out but the
wax is still there oh yeah yeah
oh I've done that before and it
definitely got rid of it super [__]
fast but also you need nose hair that's
the thing yes yeah yeah so it's also
like it's like it's like earwax right
yeah like I want to get rid of it I just
don't want the [__] dangling out of my
nose like some kind of funny
yeah yeah I feel like the nose trimmers
never work good though yeah you hear the
sound I hear the crunch running yeah
yeah and then they pull out I I like
like I pull it out and I'm like man I
there's like still like [__] two
giant pieces but I was doing like a full
excavation I feel like nose hairs only
work if you [__] tweeze it out that's
because that's what I have to do when
like mine gets too long because like the
trimmers like you said never does the
job I wanted to yeah I tweeze it as well
but I swear it comes back in like two
days
I have like mutant strength nose head
that just immediately spawn yeah you
just have a spawn point in your nose I
think I do it's so goddamn annoying it's
like it's like you died spawned right
back in here maybe I should go and do
one this wax thing so it is but I also
feel like man I kind of like having the
nice air filtration and built into my
body
says are they help like filter out oh
yeah I'm like man I also would like to
have yeah because I I definitely have
the problem of when whenever I trim my
nose here's the next day I'm sneezing
like [__] crazy yeah just because
like I I know it's like I know they do a
job but when you clean out you just
never take like a fresher breath of air
in your life I think you're mistaking
freshness for like capacity no no that's
that's the thing that's the thing I'm
like I'm like [__] time I could smell
something like Tundra from demons layer
like it's just like
I wish there was a method where I could
I could like do something extremely
painful where I'll never ever see the
nose hair but it can still just be there
uh Blazer removal no no no no it's gone
like as I should limit the growth the
hair that always wants to poke out yeah
just specifically tell those the hairs
to [__] off and never come back but the
rest I can keep because I'm fine I don't
care about having nose hair I just don't
want the ones that pop out because it's
like oh it looks [__] gross yeah all
right have you guys look at the [__]
enhance on this yeah yeah they're going
to zoom in on our noses have you guys
ever gone clean shaven down there yeah
yeah I've never okay here how do you
make it so it doesn't look
[__] weird I don't know it does you
know it always does like okay here's his
here's the Dilemma right you have like a
Johnny Sins monster [__] then it looks
great but if you have a normal sized
penis it looks weird what always weirds
me out is like my legs are like super
hairy right so so at which point do you
like draw the line you got to do like a
phase
okay so it's not just like you know it's
not just like uh oh the lawn is
completely mowed but next doors is
[__] like yeah
you gotta kind of like gradually fade it
out so it looks more natural it's just
having like a patch in your like lawn
without any grass in it and the grass is
just like fun but that's what I mean
right is that like yeah sure you know
getting a clean shaven especially in the
summer it's like oh my God my balls can
breathe right so it feels good but like
it's never gonna not look weird like you
know could you like that's like if a
tree was growing in the middle of the
street you know it it looks a bit weird
right it's like a little too flat yeah
it's the same thing right so yeah yeah
yeah I I've I think I've only ever done
it maybe like once or twice but other
than that not often not often yeah I've
heard like the itchiness because I've
never done it but yeah and again I'm
super itchy I've never done like the
full clean it's just like always you
know just taking care of it a little bit
of a trim here and there but yeah I can
I couldn't get over just like that how
do I not make this look like my legs and
my [__] balls are just completely
different the penis is gross
it's a disgusting part it is yeah so
it's never gonna not look weird but then
again it's like did you ever like have
to did you ever think to yourself like
oh I maybe you should trim because maybe
I'm going to like an Onsen or something
[Music]
the Japanese guys definitely don't give
a [__] man they don't give a [__] if
it's hiding their entire [__] penis
sometimes you can't see that PP and I'm
like is it because the hair is longer
because the peepee is short or is it
both probably for me both probably both
so you know I've never thought about
that maybe if it was like a nonsense in
a different country maybe maybe be a bit
more aware of it I'm sure there's an
evolutional need to have hair for some
reason I'm sure there's a reason for it
yeah there's always a reason for
everything yeah I don't know do you
think guys should wear makeup
okay yeah I think yeah whatever the [__]
you want to do man I mean in Japan
especially there's been like a massive
Trend in the past couple years of guys
wearing like very light makeup yeah but
like you know [__] people on TV have
been wearing makeup for decades now
right so it's like it's no different I
feel like if you care whether or not
people wear makeup it's like what are
you what's what's so boring in your life
you have time to waste caring about this
yeah yeah I know I mean like I started
wearing makeup like on and off every now
and again I've done I've like been doing
it less just because I haven't really
had time in the mornings but I remember
I guess like what kind of makeup yeah
I'm talking like lipstick
just like very light maker most of it
was just to [__] hide bags man I got
so many goddamn bags under my eyes yeah
yeah basically it's it's just like I
because I was born of like bad bags
under my eyes a lot of it's genetics
because like one of them one of the I
think the three of us have bags under
our eyes yeah yeah yeah yeah because you
can do you can get rid of it right with
like surgery or something yeah it's it's
I I've looked at the effects and it it
always gets rid of the bags but I have
like bad coloring under my eye as well
and like throughout my entire I think
we've talked about this briefly before
where my entire life it's a genetic
thing where I just look like I have
really dark under eyes and it does get
better if I get more rested but even if
I'm like fully rested have the best
night's sleep in my life I'm still gonna
have some kind of like dark coloration
on my eyes uh I wanted it to happen
sorry why does that happen it's genetics
they're like why does getting less sleep
just turn your face looking ugly I think
it's because your eyes get sunken right
is it I haven't [__] something like
that I think yeah I'm not sure exactly
what the real some some it's do of like
I guess the blood flowed to your eye
kind of like area as well
um
yeah so like for months I I've basically
looked up every kind of like let's say
cream or you know morning routine people
like eye packs oh yeah yeah literally I
did like ice packs I put cream on it and
um you know it's especially since I
started showing that was around the time
where I started showing my face more and
more often on the camera
um yeah it was you know it was something
I was trying to be a little bit more
aware of yeah uh and like I've been
using this for my entire life I've just
gotten the uh comments from my friends
or families oh you you look like you
need to get more sleep you should get
more sleep and then you know extrapolate
that to like every [__] video I'd be
in on like a YouTube comment
um and then one day I was like I was
like Sydney uh this can sound strange
but do you have any like recommendations
of like how to like hide your eye bags
for using makeup and [__] uh because she
also does have genetically like bad eye
bags yeah
yeah yeah it's almost up yeah I mean
like so so one day she was just like oh
let's just let's let's try some you know
very like very very light makeup just
like high dry bags and it was just like
a [__] night and day kind of thing I
just started wearing it and then for
like a full-on yeah I just got no
comments about my eye bags and yeah it's
not like it's not like it really really
bothers me it's just like it was just a
nice not just just not having to like
deal with those comments yes for sure
having to explain for the millionth time
no I am getting enough sleep Mum and Dad
I am getting enough sleep I slept 12
hours long yeah I just sometimes on
camera you just look at you just look
like you just got hit by a truck it's
also sometimes just like in the case
with like a video it's just like a
lighting issue sometimes just like the
bad lighting just like enhances the bags
way more because yeah lighting is a yeah
exactly so it looks sometimes it just
looks way worse on camera than it
actually